LIAISON TO ITS STAFF.
THAT’S A LOOK AT YOUR HEADLINES
SEND IT BACK TO YOU.
RACHEL: THANK YOU, JILLIAN.
BORDER MAYOR BLAMING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FOR SENDING
MIGRANTS TO HIS TOWN BY BUS.
GILA BEND ARIZONA HALF WAY
BETWEEN MEXICO AND PHOENIX AND
2,000 RESIDENTS.
MAYOR CHRIS RIGS JOINS ME NOW.
WELCOME, MAYOR.
>> THANK YOU.
RACHEL: TELL ME EXACTLY WHAT’S
HAPPENING?
THEY COME INTO YOUR TOWN ON BUS?
AND THEY DROP THEM OFF WHERE?
>> WELL, RACHEL, WHAT THEY DO IS
EITHER BRING THEM BY BUS, BY
VAN, OR EVEN BY THEIR FILL
TRUCKS.
AND THEY BRING THEM TO ONE OF
OUR COMMUNITY PARKS AND WE
REALLY DON’T HAVE A LOT OF PARKS
BUT WE HAVE ONE CENTRALIZED PARK
WHERE THEY BRING THEM.
AND THEY DROP THEM OFF THERE,
AND THEN THEY LEAF.
RACHEL: DO YOU KNOW ANYTHING?
DOES THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TELL
YOU ANYTHING ABOUT THEM, WHAT
THEIR NAMES ARE?
DO THEY HAVE A CRIMINAL HISTORY?
HAVE THEY HAD COVID TESTS?
ANYTHING?
>> THEY WILL TELL US THEY
HAVEN’T HAD A COVID TEST BECAUSE
THEY DON’T DO THAT AT THE
FACILITY.
BUT, OTHER THAN THAT, THEY ARE
GIVING US NOTHING.
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
AND WE HAVE ASKED, REPEATEDLY,
FOR DOCUMENTATION ON WHO THESE
PEOPLE ARE, WHERE THEY ARE FROM,
IF THEY DO HAVE A CRIMINAL
HISTORY, THEY WILL SOMETIMES
TELL US WELL, THEY DON’T CHECK
FOR IN THE UNITED STATES AND
THAT REALLY IS NOT WHAT I’M
CONCERNED ABOUT.
I’M MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR
COUNTRY OF ORIGIN.
RACHEL: THIS IS TRULY
OUTRAGEOUS?
HAS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
OFFERED HELP?
YOU ARE A TOWN OF 2,000?
HOW IS THIS STRAKES RESOURCES IN
STRANGE THE RESOURCES IN YOUR
TOWN?
>> THEY HAVE OFFERED NO HELP.
LAST NIGHT I LITERALLY HAD TO
DECLARE A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
I DID IT THROUGH MY COUNCIL SO
IT WAS VERY OBVIOUS.
I WASN’T TRYING TO BE POLITICAL
ABOUT IT.
THAT THIS IS BEYOND WHAT WE ARE
CAPABLE OF DOING AS A COMMUNITY
OF ABOUT 2,000 PEOPLE.
WE JUST SIMPLY CAN’T DO IT.
WE CAN’T AFFORD TO CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THESE PEOPLE AND GET
THEM TO PLACES WHERE THEY WILL
BE SAFE AND PROTECTED.
WE LITERALLY HAVE NOTHING HERE
FOR THEM.
WE HAVE NO HOUSING.
WE HAVE VERY LIMITED FOOD,
ADDITIONAL FOOD AND OTHER
RESOURCES.
>> SO I REALLY DON’T UNDERSTAND
WHY WE WERE EVEN SELECTED FOR
THESE DROPS.
RACHEL: YOU HAVE HAD NO RESPONSE
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
HAVE YOU REACHED OUT TO THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
YOU REACHED OUT TO YOUR
CONGRESSIONAL REPRESENTATIVE.
NOTHING?
>> I’M GETTING NOTHING.
THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT SEEM TO BE
WILLING TO HELP ARE A FEW OF OUR
STATE REPRESENTATIVES.
I HAVE HAD ASSISTANCE FROM
SENATOR SINEMA.
CONGRESS BIGGS, AND I HAVE HAD
ASSISTANCE FROM ARIZONA
REPRESENTATIVE I UNDERSTAND THEY
ARE TALKING TO OTHER NARROWS IN
LARGE CITIES GOOD EXAMPLE WOULD
BE THE CITY OF MESA,.
>> Maria: ON CNN.
RACHEL: REALLY QUICKLY HAS THE
CRIME RATE CHANGED AT ALL SINCE
THIS HAPPENED?
>> WE HAVE SEEN UPTICK IN CRIME.
RACHEL: THANK YOU MAYOR RIGS, WE
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US ON THE
SHOW.
THIS IS REALLY JUST UNBELIEVABLE
STORY.
WE WONDER WHERE ELSE IT’S
HAPPENING?
THANK YOU FOR SHARING THIS